we are here at the shape body shop event
why is it so important for you to be
here today this event is huge I just
love everything that it represents you
know my shape and and representing who
you are and loving your body and loving
your own shape and owning that shape and
speaking of your shape you look amazing
I'm I literally in coming here today
thought I'll just ask her what do I do
to beat you is this the best you've ever
felt yeah you know I think that growing
up it was it was never an issue for me
to think about like working out or
having a healthy lifestyle because I
dance so much but then when I kind of
stopped dancing and I got into regular
life mode I didn't realize how much you
know diet and nutrition and and being
active was so important not only for my
physical shape but for my mental state
too now what about Brooks he's a hockey
player he's sowing shake you guys
workout together or keep that separate
it's fun to hang out with each other and
push each other and also kind of show
him like hey I can keep up with a
professional athlete watch you know so
it's fun he seems like such a great guy
I mean you have your dogs and he seems
to like love your dog so much I mean
literally they are pride and joy they're
our furry little babies already so yeah
you talked a little bit about having
kids I know you come from a big family
do you think about how many kids you
want to have do you want to do the big
family thing I mean that's definitely
kind of been our mindset for a long time
but
one step at a time I mean I'm sure like
once it actually starts happening I'm
like what my sister actually she's right
there she's in town with her family and
she has six kids so that's a lot of
practice already and we're already
thinking about taking a trip to Costco
and like loading up on in bulk you know
so they eat a lot kids eat a lot buy all
that toilet paper he seems like he gets
along so well with your family how did
you know he was the guy I've never
really been the person to really think
about like when you know you know but it
was just kind of that yeah we first met
each other and we're like and we're done
yeah